you'll find i often do this but today
what i'd like to do is
leave space for a heading i really hate
when a heading is a spoiler for what
you're actually going
to learn don't worry i'll fill it in and
if i forget just tell me and then we'll
fill it in
you might feel like these questions that
arrived at these answers are kind of
like really
is this what i signed up to extension to
to do um
like i said it starts off gentle and it
gets gets it really fast
you actually did unbeknownst to you a
history lesson just as you were going
through
these questions i'd love you to have if
you've got another color
next to whatever color you just did
these questions pull that out
and if you do not have another color
borrow from someone and then fix that
because you'll find colors are going to
be very very useful in communicating
and understanding what you're doing here
we went through a potted history
of all the different kinds of numbers
that we as mathematicians
use all the time and these are pretty
familiar right
the first number is the most basic kind
of number that anyone has ever come up
with and i'm going to introduce some
symbols here
which you need to be aware of this is an
n you can see it's got two
sort of solid lines through which is
part of set notation when you see these
two lines going through you know this is
not just a pronumeral
this stands for a whole set of different
numerals
this n stands for does anyone have a
guess a very basic important part
of the number system the natural numbers
very good
i'm also called the counting numbers
because that's exactly
what we do with them we count one two
three four since prehistory
before things were written down we were
counting
right but fairly quickly we realized
there are more numbers than just one two
three four
and so on these numbers here are not
natural numbers they're not counting
numbers you don't count up to a half
does anyone know what family of numbers
this belongs to
any takers yeah go ahead start with an r
by the way rational numbers very good
now because we like to try and be
completely sensible
the symbol for rational numbers
is not an r it's a q does anyone want to
guess why
might it be q what word to do with this
starts with a q this is division right
think think go ahead question very good
so so that q is a reference to that idea
rational numbers again in the name it's
about a ratio
between two numbers and so we're pretty
familiar
with those but they took a while to
develop in terms of mathematics
uh xero kind of sort of doesn't belong
especially into any particular
family but i do wonder does anyone know
how long did it take us to come up with
the idea
of zero does anyone know roughly when it
came into vogue
i'll give you a clue way later
than you would think any takers anyone
have just hazard a guess
when do you think we really came up with
this idea and yeah go ahead
1900s so it was a long
time ago longer than the 1900s though so
we did a little bit better than that
from memory it's the
1100s which is still like oh it's like
at least we've got like a millennium
sort of but still
just think about how long we've been
doing these and how long it took us to
come with this idea
of zero i should point out by the way um
hindu and
hindu mathematicians in india beat us by
several centuries so i think it's really
important that we recognize that
mathematics is universal pursuit then we
come down to these guys
uh back in year seven we call these
directed numbers but they have a more
technical name starts with an i don't
remember these are the integers again
because we want to mess with you the
symbol for integers is not an eye does
anyone know what symbol is
it's a z very good again with those two
lines there
a reference to the german mathematicians
um who did a lot of exploration in this
field
zales at ahl is a german for counting or
counter
and then this last one down here doesn't
belong to any of these
sets oh we call this
we'll call it irrational which is why
irrational it's a name that means
not one of these right we just take that
symbol the q
and we pop a um a tilde on the over the
top which means
not that right not in the set
of rational numbers now the important
thing i want to get across to you as we
looked
through these is that each set of
numbers it kind of breaks the rules
of the previous set of numbers right um
if for example
you have a look at part d right if you
asked uh
like a five-year-old child to subtract
some numbers they could do it she said
hey what's seven take away three
they'd look at their fingers for a
second and then they would repeat to you
four no problems but if you ask the same
child can you tell me what three
take away seven is do it the other way
they'd be like they'd get their fingers
out and then they'd say okay well here's
my three and then i start taking away to
get to seven and i'm like oh you can't
do it
no answer right now this was you many
years ago
okay but we came to realize there's more
to this than just the things that you
can count
if we put direction on these numbers
that's actually really useful for things
like
temperature or debt finance is actually
where these are really really useful
now this is kind of where we've gone i
should put on one more if you want to
put an
f on here for reasons that are actually
really deep and profound i couldn't
write an equation that would do this but
you've got numbers like these guys right
everything you just saw here they're
what we call the algebraic numbers
because you can form them with the rules
of algebra
pi and e you can't do that with those
guys so they are not
algebraic there's the a for algebraic
numbers so they're not
algebraic but because these numbers are
so wicked and cool we give them an even
more special name
we call them and this has to be one of
the greatest names in all of
naming anything really we call these
guys the transcendental
numbers okay now if you take everything
there
this is all the numbers you've ever had
to do anything
with in 12 years of schooling
all these guys as a big happy family
they belong to one big sort of superset
if you like and this one is
part of the reason why we don't use the
r for this this one does start with an
r it's a name maybe you've heard of do
you know what these are called the real
numbers thank you
the real numbers these guys are what
you've been playing ball with and as you
can see
they're inclusive of centuries of
mathematical
development the real numbers they're
pretty cool
just one teeny little problem yeah
question oh are we distribution between
end
and influence uh i'm going to leave that
very very important distinction
off of this discussion mainly because
i'm talking here about our progression
through there doesn't include zero or
not you can see i delightfully dodged
that question a little bit
we can have a discussion about that
another time when we have more time
good question though so there are
numbers right um
they include a lot of things but there
are signs
in the mathematics you've already done
that actually there's more to the
universe than this and my clue there are
many different clues
but my clue was in this pair of
questions that i gave you here
right sum and product of roots
some product of roots let's have a think
about these guys for a second
uh not this whiteboard marker
this was the equation i gave you sorry
the expression i gave you
for that sum product of roots and then
from memory i think the expression was
this right
is this right yeah okay great now here's
what i'd like you to do
i hope you went directly like this
whoever did this working did
to alpha beta equals how did you get
that by the way it's
what ratio is it's minus b on a
fantastic and then for this it's
c on a okay so we can go directly to
those results without knowing let's just
write that here
without knowing what alpha and beta are
you can still work out
what the independent sum and product are
right can you go ahead just for the sake
of it go ahead and solve this guy
right you're going to get alpha and b
can you do that because i just need to
wake up something on my screen for a
second
[Music]
[Applause]
okay that didn't take long right go
ahead and tell me
um i keep on picking up the same pen uh
go ahead and tell me it doesn't matter
which one's which obviously
uh what are alpha and beta what'd you
get
negative three and fantastic and
we could interchange them that's fine so
we're like no big deal of course they
are negative 3 and negative 2 because
you factorize this as x plus 2 x plus 3
or whatever method you chose went for
the quadratic formula if you were
particularly
masochistic and you can see this
confirms exactly what we saw here before
right you add these two together you get
negative five
you multiply them you get six all good
right
except something weird happens when you
just have a look at this other
seemingly harmless quadratic and to
illustrate this we're going to draw
something
um you're going to see if for those of
you who are not mrs lisa's class you
might not know
we have an obsession with graphing even
things you're like why would you graph
that that's let's say graph we make your
graph anyway because it's
instructful it helps you see things so i
want you to draw from me a set of axes a
cartesian plane
and what i'd like to do is to take this
quadratic
and to graph it now i'm going to do it
in a slightly unusual way
there are many ways to graph y equals x
squared plus two x plus four
but i'm going to try and call on the
knowledge of what you developed in
actually it was a round was around
lockdown time actually when we were
doing
graphing techniques in the advanced
course right
and functions like this we could think
of in terms of
transformations like stretching dilation
shifts that kind of thing okay so to do
that i'm going to take this guy here
and the first thing i'm going to do is
i'm going to separate out that
4 on the end there i'm going to separate
it out into
two different numbers two different
numbers that are both inside
four that will come from completing the
square on this guy now you might think
completely squares a bit out of left
field why am i completing the square
this seems
rather unnecessary stay with me it will
be useful in a second
to complete the square what do you add
to x squared plus 2x
you add one right because you take this
coefficient here you have it and you
square it
in this case you have you get one you
square it you get one
so that's the one there okay that leaves
as part of that
four that leaves a three on this side
okay with that one plus three is four
we're all good the reason why we
complete the square is it's a useful way
to factorize right so this thing here is
a perfect square
namely x
plus 1 or squared i'm not that old but
you're going to need to speak up a
little bit for me
year 12 because um yeah my hearing's not
that great so there's my perfect square
now this plus three i hope you can see
it is actually going back to graphing
techniques right it's actually not
interacting
with the x it's not about a horizontal
shift it's really though it's on the
right hand side it's really
interacting with the y it's actually a
vertical shift so i'm going to write it
in this form y
minus 3 equals is that okay same deal
3 on that side negative 3 on this side
okay why is this helpful why is this a
good way to write this
because when i come to graph i can now
think of this as a regular old parabola
like y equals x squared
with two differences what are the two
differences those are the two numbers
there
can someone tell me one what does the y
minus three do
how is it different to my regular
parabola
it makes it go up by three units it's
been raised so that's really good
so instead of being at the origin i'm
going to be up this way and then what
about the other
shift what's that left by one fantastic
so instead
of my vertex being at the origin my
vertex is now going to be
you said up by 3 left by 1. so let's go
ahead and put that on here
i'm going to call that negative 1 comma
three so far so good and that's the
vertex so everything goes up
from there okay so what does this help
us see
well before i told you anything about
this graph or explained all of this
business right
you very merrily went through and did
your minus b on a and your c
on a and you've got some really
reasonable answers
out of the sum and product of roots
there's just this
one little problem this thing has no
roots
right like don't you remember having to
answer questions about this
have a look at this thing tell us what
the discriminant is does it have real
roots does it have distinctives does it
have any roots at all
you would have normally have said this
thing doesn't have
roots and here is my evidence right